South Korea's president is speaking out
about the death of otto warmbier moon
jae-in is also calling for direct talks
with the North Korean regime nor
O'Donnell spoke with president moon at
his residence just hours after news of
warm beers death broke she joins us now
from Seoul South Korea nor a good
morning to you
hey good morning to you Gayle that's
right this is president moon's first
television interview and it comes ahead
of this big summit that he's going to
have with President Trump next week at
the White House he is promising this
fundamental shift in how to deal with
North Korea so we asked president moon
how this news of otto warmbier x' death
may affect this new strategy we have
learned that otto warmbier
a 22 year old american student has died
what are your thoughts on his passing
was some otto warmbier first of all i
would like to convey my deepest
condolences to the bereaved family of
mr. otto warmbier and the American
people for the sorrow and shock they are
suffering through yoga we can make
speculations that there were many unjust
and cruel treatments to mr. warmbier and
I strongly condemn such cruel actions by
North Korea even today there are many
Korean nationals and American citizens
who are detained in North Korea I also
urged North Korea to return these people
to their families Senator John McCain
has said that otto warmbier was murdered
by the Kim jong-un regime do you believe
the North Koreans should be held
responsible for his death gross amoeba
yes this had happened while mr. warmbier
was in the detention of North Korean
authorities we cannot know for sure that
North Korea killed mr. warmbier but I
believe it is quite clear that they have
a heavy responsibility in the process
that led to mr. wannabe ours death how
does this affect your efforts to restart
the dialogue with North Korea Oh son I
believe we must now have the perception
that North Korea is an irrational regime
working with such a country we must
achieve the goal
the complete dismantling of North
Korea's nuclear program
how do you sit knee to knee as you
promised with an irrational leader and
negotiate the ohan I believe that
dialogue is necessary we were unable to
resolve the North Korean nuclear issue
through only the sanctions and pressure
the idea of engaging in dialogue with
North Koreans before they are
denuclearized is fundamentally at odds
with long-standing US policy so what are
you going to say to President Trump when
you meet with him next week
Khushi I believe that my position is not
at odds with the policy of the United
States or that of President Trump it
seems to me that President Trump has
criticized the failed former policies of
his predecessor administrations and on
that point I have the same view as
President Trump but it's not clear that
even under President Trump that he will
agree to allow you to negotiate with the
North Koreans without any preconditions
and you want to do that you want to
start a dialogue without any concessions
by the North Koreans aren't you giving
in to them current Aharon I have never
mentioned a dialogue with no
preconditions whatsoever I believe that
first they must vie for a freeze of
North Korea's nuclear and missile
programs and then as a second phase try
to achieve the complete dismantling of
North Korea's nuclear program and I
believe there are voices supporting such
a step-by-step approach even within the
United States and part of that
step-by-step approach is president moon
believes he's going to get the green
light from president Trump to have these
bilateral talks with North Korea to
begin this inter-korean dialogue part of
that as well is whether president moon
thinks he can go to Pyongyang and meet
directly with Kim jong-un to try and
denuclearize North Korea or at least
begin this freeze charlie
junyeong has said that his nuclear
program is non-negotiable why should he
be willing to engage in a freeze it's a
great question and that's the question
we asked why would he agree to a freeze
I mean what concessions does he want
what are the South Koreans going to give
him and what president moon said is that
the North Korean leader has this blind
faith that that's what's keeping his
regime alive and they're going to try
and make him believe through talks that
they can be a stable regime without that
nor O'Donnell in Seoul thank you so much